le ministre de l'intérieur s'attaque au
minitel rose au nom de la protection des
mineurs et dénonce les partis
d'opposition qui défendent de gros
intérêts financiers basés sur l'apologie
du sexe
interview de monsieur pasqua publié par
la haute-marne libérer la vague des
minutes à la clé une sorte de vide
juridique et monsieur pasqua craint le
développement du proxénétisme via les
petites abus la theurre enquête parce
castelletta mêmes mayol téléphone rose
et les messageries coquine sur minitel
sont deux façons moderne d'assouvir bien
des fantasmes pour dialoguer avec
isabelle sur minitel l'entendre au
téléphone la voix suave et racoleuse de
géraldine
le tarif est le même 73 centimes toutes
les 45 secondes
il ya aujourd'hui deux millions et demi
de minitel en service les messageries
c'est à dire la possibilité de dialoguer
avec d'autres usagers représentent 16%
de l'ensemble du trafic
en tout un chiffre d'affaires de plus
d'un milliard de francs pour l'année 86
et fournisseurs de services partagés
deux tiers du pactole l'état récupère le
reste nous assurons la communication de
manière entièrement libres sans contrôle
et le contenu c'est à dire que vous
servez uniquement de véhicules
c'est ça nous savons véhicules et nous
assurerons la liberté d'accès aux
réseaux avec 5 millions d'appels par an
pour le téléphone rose et cent mille
heures de connexion sur le minitel par
mois le groupe téléphone est l'un des
trusts du fantasme la recette est simple
un appartement de 100 m² quelques
minutes elle d'été les animatrices et
l'exploitation intelligente des délires
d'autrui
le minitel est un service public je veux
dire aujourd'hui il y en ile de france
deux personnes sur trois qui sont des
solitaires grâce au minitel ils vont
avoir la possibilité de se rencontrer
le minitel est complètement je dirais
trans rang social
si on en voit uniquement je dirais
l'aspect très limité q la superbe je
dirais sordide que peut avoir parfois le
minitel c'est 3% du minitel
les dérapages sont pourtant inévitable
mais l'été les animatrices sont là pour
veiller au grain les prostituées qui ont
déjà arrivé c'est déjà arrivé
et moi j'ai de quoi donc dans ces cas-là
on lit des collectes
c'est à dire pour faire en sorte que
leur minitel s'éteignent rien ne peut
cependant pour l'instant empêcher un
enfant d'accéder aux messageries
érotique
on peut s'interroger si à travers ce
nouveau mode de communication
il ne revient pas il n'est pas
nécessaire de repenser complètement
l'organisation juridique pour protéger
la jeunesse
l'idée me semble-t-il n'est pas
d'interdire mais de permettre une
diffusion beaucoup plus restreinte
un peu comme en matière de cinéma pour
les films tact et x films
pornographiques
on peut toutefois se demander s'il est
techniquement possible d'interdire le
minitel aux moins de 16 ans